[Música]
ele falou de medo é interessante isso é
e hoje também vou falar de medo
essa foi a minha luta minha primeira
luta no fc aos 35 anos em dezembro de
2014 eu cheguei de ônibus por trás da do
ginásio e um staff do fc ele já nos pega
e já leva à porta do ginásio e na porta
do ginásio tinha um papel uma folha a4
escrito assim victor miranda renan barão
é erick silva e lyoto machida eu e meu
deus que estou fazendo aqui
até aquele momento o meu sentimento era
normal natural pra mim eu já tenho mais
de 50 lutas profissionais
eu estou acostumado entrar no ginásio
para lutar mas quando eu vi naquele
papel escrito junto com o meu nome os
melhores lutadores do mundo dentro do
mma
eu senti medo porque eu pensei agora é
pra valer
agora eu vou estar lutando no fc o maior
evento de lutas do mundo contra o
americano e o mundo inteiro estará me
vendo e será me assistindo não dessa vez
não é só minha família e meus amigos que
estavam vendo que também já é bastante
difícil só que dessa vez o mundo inteiro
estará prestando atenção em mim e eu
super apreensivo é entrei no vestiário e
de pensar ea cimpor mas pelo menos é a
primeira luta da noite
só que a primeira luta da noite ela que
dita o ritmo da noite pode ser uma noite
chata os fãs ou pode ser uma noite
excitante eu tinha essa responsabilidade
de táxi ritmo então a apreensão foi
crescendo cada vez mais
mas aí por último eu pensei ah mas tudo
bem é a primeira luta da noite bruta de
abertura não terão tantos espectadores
na arena
só que não é a minha luta estava
prevista para as 19 horas às 16 e 30 a
área estava lotada
dava pra ouvir o barulho das pessoas lá
no vestiário
geralmente 40 minutos antes da minha
luta eu preciso começar a crescer
só que naquele momento estava estava
assim em posição fetal deitada também e
tentando imaginando poxa tem que ligar
pra minha mãe para me tirar daqui sabe
mas não teve jeito meu treinador me
chamou foi o victor está na hora da
gente crescer vamos lá eu levantei com
as pernas ainda meio meio bambas e
começa o aquecimento é alongamento
primeiro depois eu me movi começa a se
movimentar mais rápido faz nos posições
as movimentações de luta no ar depois na
manopla começam a repassar a estratégia
de luta tanto como treinador como
mentalmente
quando chega o staff dentro do vestiário
fala cinco minutos ea linha já estou a
mil por hora coração acelerar disse mú a
boca seca assim como está agora e toda
hora tem que tomar um gole de água pra
me manter calmo quando ele grita um
minuto
e aí eu vou eu saí do vestiário ele me
acompanha até a cortina onde sê para o
backstage da torcida
e aí eu aguardo o meu momento o momento
de entrada até o pentágono
quando ele dá o sinal e aguarda o clipe
de apresentação é que está passando um
telão quando termina ele dá um sinal e
eu começa a caminhar até octógono
eu fixo meu olhar da câmera faz uma cara
de brabo mas na verdade o gelado por
dentro a todo momento ainda estou
pensando a cimpor tem uma coisa que
possa acontecer pra não acontecer essa
luta eu torceu o pé que caíram poder
lutar alguém da arquibancada cair à luz
a pagar qualquer coisa mas a cada passo
que eu dava eu me aproximava do problema
e o problema era o adversário estava
esperando do outro lado quando a gente
pensa que um ser humano ele treina todos
os dias durante dois meses três meses
para me vencer para me derrotar
sabendo que ele acorda pensando e dorme
pensando em maneiras estratégias de
bater no meu rosto batendo na cara
ninguém venceu
isso vai muito mais isso vai vai muito
além da da competição vai muito além do
esporte e é por essa razão que a gente
sentiu medo maior do que o normal
finalmente eu chego na frente do catch
me que é um cara que passar vaselina e
aí ele faz uma vistoria geral passa a
vaselina e eu olho fechado ali querendo
que esse momento não terminasse que ele
ficasse ali por muito tempo porque a
hora que ele me liberar para subir no
octógono aí não tem mais jeito aí será
il contra o adversário
inevitavelmente esse momento chega ele
me libera eu dou um abraço nos
treinadores
subo os três degraus com bastante
cuidado que tem até octógono
coloco meus pés primeiro entrou com o pé
direito depois que o esquerdo
e aí a hora de enfrentar os medos até
que vocês conseguiram tão nervosos
quanto eu conseguem sentir a pressão e o
sentimento o medo que eu sentia naquele
dia e se sim quarta esse sentimento não
esqueçam dele porque agora é a hora de
voltar no tempo
em junho de 2011 mais precisamente
era uma tarde era uma segunda feira uma
tarde bem bonita cheio de sol lá na
flórida em boca raton no sul da flórida
onde eu morava com a minha esposa paula
o meu filho igor de quatro anos na
verdade fase e um estava três dias
quatro dias para ele completar quatro
anos e lembro que tinha três anos ainda
e há quatro dias depois ele ia fazer
três fazer quatro
eu depois do almoço me despedir deles
peguei o carro e fui pra academia dá uma
aula eu dava uma aula de muay thai é por
um personal às 16 horas
como a cidade ela não tinha trânsito e
eu demorava 20 minutos para chegar ou
sair de casa 15 40 15 e 59 eu estacionei
o carro na frente da academia quando o
telefone toca
antes de eu desligar a chave do carro eu
vejo a foto da minha mulher no telefone
eu geralmente não atendo já nesse
horário porque já ia me atrasasse
atendesse mas tudo bem não entrei na
academia vai entender
eu coloquei telefone no ouvido ouvir a
voz dela só que era uma voz transformada
uma voz diferente carregada de muito
muito terror e ela estava gritando
desesperadamente um telefone e ela
conseguiu articular seguinte frase
victor me ajuda o igor caiu na piscina
ele está morto
o medo que eu senti que caiu sobre mim
naquele momento ele é indescritível é
destruidor
eu pensei em alguma coisa pra
exemplificar isso pra vocês ea única
maneira que encontrei aqui vocês
visualizem comigo
mentalizem comigo a seguinte situação
quando você é criança
lembra quando você é criança e fez
alguma coisa errada você sabe que é
errada ea tua mãe fala assim olha se
prepare continental
apanhar sabe se tiro na barriga guardar
ele acumula ele aí depois você pensa um
pouco mais velho quando você está
prestes a fazer aquela prova dificílima
que depende de uma nota alta para passar
e você sabe que não estudou e e frio na
barriga aquele nervosismo acumula-se
também aí depois você pensa no seu
primeiro beijo na sua primeira
entrevista de emprego a sua primeira
palestra seu primeiro toque você pensa
naquela decisão de campeonato mundial
tudo isso se você conseguiu visualizar
isso você agora está como um estômago
apertado com dificuldades de respirar
com aquele frio na barriga
aí você pega esse sentimento
coloque uma pitada de terror uma pitada
de pânico e multiplica por 10 mil 100
mil milhão 10 milhões não importa porque
chega um momento que a gente é não
consegue mais identificar o que é muito
o que é pouco que é real que a ilusão
nós entramos em choque ea minha e eu
falei pra minha esposa assim
olhas tenha calma faça massagem cardíaca
e respiração boca a boca vira de lado
dela falou eu já fiz tudo isso não está
adiantando
eu falei continuar fazendo o que eu vou
ligar para o 911 e eles vão chegar muito
rápido eu desliguei o telefone e liguei
para o 911 e pra casa novamente quando
cheguei em casa a eles já estavam
colocando igor na ambulância que foi
onde que eu presenciei aquela cena e me
ajoelhei berrando lá gritando
desesperado corri para perto da minha
esposa
e esse medo avassalador tomou conta da
gente e nos dominou por quatro dias
mas infelizmente esse medo ele virou uma
realidade
quatro dias depois ele ele
ele ficou em coma há quatro dias
exatamente no dia do aniversário dele
faleceu dia 24 de junho de 2011
eu contei essa história pra vocês essas
experiências que eu tive para vocês
perceberem que eu sei que assim tinha
medo
os brutos também amam a gente é carne e
osso é assim como vocês também sentem
muito medo de alguma coisa de alguma
situação seja o medo positivo aqui igual
àquele da luta do fc que eu pude que
tive oportunidade de me preparar para
esse grande dia seja o medo negativo
como a morte do meu filho onde eu não
tinha o que fazer a não ser rezar para
que o melhor
o pior não acontecesse e com a minha
experiência com as nossas experiências
eu aprendi que a gente precisa a gente
precisa alimentar o medo inteligente
nós precisamos promover esse medo
inteligente porque o medo ante
inteligente e antecipado
ele faz a gente te forças de motivação e
de energia para a gente se preparar pra
gente se proteger se precaver e impedir
que o pior aconteça
por isso que eu digo
o medo é um privilégio por exemplo se
agendando uma floresta
a gente vê uma cobra se a gente sentiu
medo antecipado inteligente
antes da cobra se aproximar a gente
consegue achar maneira uma estratégia de
evitar essa cobra se a gente ver a cobra
e não tem medo ela vai explicar e depois
que ela ficará inevitavelmente vai
sentir medo
só que em um medo emergencial um medo
que não tem o que a gente fazer só rezar
para que o veneno não tome conta do
nosso corpo de chegar no hospital
o medo inteligente e antecipado ele fez
com que eu me preparasse muito bem para
todas as minhas lutas mesmo depois de 20
anos de carreira
o medo inteligente antecipado ele faz
hoje eu não tirar os olhos das minhas
filhas quando elas estão perto da
piscina no apartamento que a gente mora
hoje junto com minha esposa e minhas
duas pequenas uma de 5 anos e uma de
seis meses para você saber então gente
eu convido vocês a promoverem produzirem
estimularem medos inteligentes
o medo inteligente vai fazer vai fazer
com que cada um de vocês se preocupe e
proteja e se prepare para guardar aquilo
que é mais sagrado e mais precioso pra
vocês
obrigado
[Aplausos]